hey guys today we're gonna talk about
distilled water and in a minute fasting
so what is distilled water basically
boiling the water concentrating the
vapor and you're getting rid of the
impurities and minerals okay and this
purifies the water
okay there's other types of purified
water deionized water which is a
chemical process and you're placing
these minerals in the water with
hydrogen and hydroxide and there's also
another type of purified water called
reversed osmosis which involves a
membrane which allows certain particles
to go through and pressure this
eliminates virtually all the minerals as
well and people are using purified water
and distilled water in certain
detoxification programs and some people
have this idea that it's a healthier
long-term but here's the big problem
when you consume distilled water it will
deplete your minerals and your
electrolytes okay which are basically
the same thing so I'm talking about
calcium magnesium potassium sodium
chlorides so the more you drink of this
water the more it pulls out the minerals
especially if you're doing it long-term
short-term I think it's going to be fine
especially if you're consuming
electrolytes you know your foods but
when you start doing an immanent fasting
program okay and you're doing maybe some
periodic prolonged fasting with that and
you're using reverse osmosis water or
distilled water
you're gonna deplete your mineral
reserves in this constituent for all
sorts of problems specifically heart
problems because you need these
electrolytes for the heart to work
correctly and so many people when they
start a fasting program are going into
it with existing mineral deficiencies so
we don't want to add anything else
that's going to deplete them and this is
why I always recommend when you're doing
fasting to take electrolytes in your
water when you drink the water so the
best water to consume when you're doing
fasting especially is to do spring water
well water hard water which is full of
minerals calcium and magnesium growing
up in Wisconsin we had some incredible
well water we didn't have to filter it
at all we just drank it right from the
tap
it's loaded with calcium the type of
calcium that
goes in like a rocket ship because it's
calcium bicarbonate now when you heat
water for example when you're making tea
you notice those little white crystals
on the bottom that is calcium carbonate
okay
so heat turns to bicarbonate into
carbonate which is really hard to absorb
like in a lot of supplements like
one-a-days and things like that they use
calcium carbonate which is like you're
consuming rocks but calcium bicarbonate
in hard water or spring water is the
best type of calcium and as a side note
a lot of people use soft water compare
the hard water what does that basically
replace these minerals like calcium and
magnesium with sodium and bicarbonate
it's they like it because it it doesn't
leave that soap scum and that white
white film around your clothing when you
wash your clothes like hard water does
but the problem is you want to drink
water with these minerals because the
minerals actually help you they give you
the electrolytes that you need so the
moral of story is that if you're doing
fasting okay do not do stew stilled
water and if you want to do distilled
water only do it short term do not do a
long term unless you're taking
electrolytes all right guys thanks for
watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it